morgen ab 10 uhr soll es wohl losgehen
da will sich dann die kanzlerin mit
ihren 16 länderchefs bei einer schalte
besprechen und ich möchte mich jetzt
besprechen mit meinem kollegen sebastian
geisler der bier im studio ist sebastian
was wird denn da morgen beschlossen bei
diesem großen corona gipfel genau aus
elena so morgen abziehen wollen sich die
16 regierungschefs der bundesländer und
kanzlerin angela merkel zusammenschalten
diesmal als telefonkonferenz dass ein
harter locker und kommt also schließung
von geschäften und weitere
einschränkungen im schulbetrieb gilt als
sicher die wichtigste frage ist jetzt
kommt der harte lockdown wir in sachsen
ab montag schonend gelten soll
bundesweit schon am montag oder wie von
kanzlerin merkel vorgeschlagen erst ab
mittwoch oder möglicherweise auch erst
zum wochenende
da gibt es zurzeit offenbar in der
beschlussvorlage noch keine einigkeit
klar ist der lok downlight der unser
weihnachtsfest ja retten sollte gilt als
gescheitert die ministerpräsidenten und
auch bundespolitiker überbieten sich
damals wie jetzt mit forderungen
schnellstmöglich den lock down zu
verschärfen
die eigentlich angedachten lockerungen
die uns ja ein schönes weihnachtsfest
ermöglichen sollten gelten jetzt als
nicht mehr zu verantworten
nur noch geschäfte des täglichen bedarfs
sondern offen bleiben die frage ist
jetzt ab wann soll und das ganze geld
absolut und die kanzlerin möchte ja auch
gerne eine gemeinsame linie fahren das
hat bisher ja noch nicht so wirklich
geklappt bei ihren deutschland was sind
denn die möglichkeiten also eigentlich
wurde man ja erst nach weihnachten in
den verschärften locker umgehen hessens
ministerpräsident bouffier ging zuletzt
von ansteckungen nach weihnachten aus
bayerns ministerpräsident söder und
nrw-ministerpräsident lasche wollen aber
schnellstmöglich schon den lockdown
haben wohl schon vor der wochenmitte die
befürchtung ist wenn am mittwoch
zugemacht wird strömen die leute vorher
noch zum weihnachtsshopping in die
geschäfte deswegen heißt es jetzt jüngst
auch aus rheinland-pfalz vielleicht
gestatten wir das gar nicht mehr
vielleicht machen wir am montag schon zu
problem ist aber auch dass eine solche
verordnung erstmal natürlich
rechtssicher ausgearbeitet werden muss
und das braucht möglicherweise auch ein
zwei tage ja und ganz spannende frage
was wird alles genau zu machen
ja unbedingt also supermärkte und wohl
auch drogerien bleiben auf in sachsen
sollen ab montag anders als im ersten
lauf dann übrigens aber auch zum
beispiel die baumärkte dichtmachen
apotheken und
tankstellen bleiben auch in sachsen
offen auch friseure auch übrigens
weihnachtsbaumverkauf soll erlaubt sein
betroffen vom lockdown wären auch die
schulen um kinder ist auch ganz
wichtiger punkt in nordrhein westfalen
wird etwa dazu aufgerufen die kinder
möglichst nicht mehr in die kita zu
bringen da gibt es aber wohl noch so
eine ahnung betrieb bei den schulen gibt
es zwischen den bundesländern allerdings
auch ganz unterschiedliche ansätze wir
wissen ich schleswig holstein und
mecklenburg vorpommern zum beispiel sind
nicht so stark betroffen vom
infektionsgeschehen wie die hotspots wie
beispielsweise sachsen deswegen geht es
da er so in die richtung ob man
möglicherweise dann auch die gitarren
unterricht machen kann aufhebung von
präsenzpflicht während er andere eben
dann tatsächlich man spricht ja dann
immer von verlängerten schulferien im
grunde sind das natürlich
schulschließungen die da verhängt werden
interessant ist der punkt ob es
möglicherweise ausgangs beschränkungen
gibt das ist in baden württemberg von
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
heute schon verhängt worden da darf man
seit heute nur noch aus triftigen
gründen vor die tür
und zwar nur noch zwischen 5 und 20 uhr
in sachsen sollen ab montag eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre gelten das
wären zwischen 22 und 6 uhr so etwas
könnte im äußersten fall dann auch
bundesweit kommen die zähne zusammen
beißen weil jetzt gerade über
weihnachten ist ja eine sehr schwere
zeit das alles so einzuhalten
wie lange würden diese maßnahmen denn
gelten wissen wird da schon was also ein
termine immer wieder genannt wurde war
der zehnte januar da so ein kritiker
aber das sei willkürlich gewählt diese
starb und reiche nicht aus da länger
tiefer in den januar hinein geben bis
mitte januar vielleicht darüber sogar
hinaus am harten lockdown festhalten das
wird ein streitpunkt sein und silvester
ist ja so eine zeit wo man dann gerne
ein bisschen party macht und mehrere
leute trifft wie wird's denn da aussehen
ja auch da will man natürlich möglichst
größere menschenansammlungen vermeiden
wenn die leute alle rausgehen feuerwehr
gucken zum böllern geht vielleicht
anstoßen und so was also spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach will
da nach französischem vorbild sogar eine
ausgangssperre ab 20 uhr da müssen wir
also den jahreswechsel in der wohnung
feiern will er auch verbieten er sagt
dann gibts auch gar nicht groß was zu
feiern dieses jahr klar ist wenn
menschen miteinander feiern alkohol im
spiel es ist immer schwierig mit dem
abstand halten und so weiter
problem ist aber da müssen wir ehrlich
sein die politik kann natürlich viel
verbieten aber der staat sprich polizei
ordnungsämter müssen das dann auch
umsetzen dass das kontrolliert und
eingehalten wird und dafür braucht man
wenn man so etwas erlassen so wurde eben
die konzepte und auch erstmal nicht nur
beratung und viele viele beamte die das
dann auch tun sebastian geisler vielen
dank jetzt für diese informationen die
ich von dir bekommen habe und einen
schönen abend noch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren